[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad well it's not often you
get a guest on who has a story so
incredible that it's turned into a
blockbuster movie but today we have just
the lad he honestly has one of the most
incredible 40 careers which saw him play
all around the world on some of the
biggest stages there is none bigger than
the 2011 rugby world cup where he became
the hero of a nation and off the field
he is widely regarded as one of the
greatest lads to ever play the game it
is the one and only stephen donald
welcome beef
thanks for having me mate some intro uh
i don't know what that means as far as
uh off the field but uh i'll take it
mate lots of lots of questions came in
for you you sound like an absolute
rooster
no i mean uh we've all got to check it
passed um
me know
more so than me but uh yeah
enjoyed enjoyed my time that's for sure
mate and speaking about your time like a
lot of guys have up and down careers but
matt your roller coaster must have been
some right
yeah i mean
i guess you know like at the end of it
all now i'm glad it was you know it
would have been you know it would be
nice to have one of those beautiful
plain sailing careers and uh everything
was rosy but i think you know
sort of person i wasn't even gonna be
like that and had to scrap for a fair
bit of it so
now i mean obviously it was it was some
ride and look back and think geez you
know how did it all unfold like that at
times yeah
and then yeah i mean there was some dark
days and there's some obviously the
highest of highest but uh
you know i guess
oh the whole thing is
yeah it's just a it was a bizarre sort
of
15 or whatever years it was and uh just
in the end just loved every minute of it
but at the time when you when you're
deep in some of those uh darker days
it's uh it was tough yeah and you've
done a seamless transition post footy
look at you now uh on the scenes radio
every afternoon one of the great shows
um have you found that have you found
being on the radio
yeah i mean obviously uh or your small
relationship with the media um in my
playing career probably wasn't the
greatest so uh
to now be you know media
persons but a bit different but um
no i've enjoyed it i want to curse stan
away every day so to the proper
professional um and uh and i just come
with my uh my [ __ ] channel on the side
of it but uh she she keeps the thing
going but uh i mean i've been lucky you
know you say talk about life after footy
then it's a pretty it's a pretty nice
one to swing into um or starting to
think you know what is what is around
the corner and yeah what is going to
fold like i guess
so many of us do mate we stress a little
bit once you know that sort of the last
japanese paycheck has been banked at uh
yeah
it came at a nice time obviously
on the back of the covered stuff um it
was nice to swing into this one so she
obviously does all the prep for the
shows and all that and sort of just
gives you the run run down when you
arrive
oh look she'll tell you it i mean i do
arrive a good hour or so before kicking
off um but uh yeah she she's got she's
got everything covered in case it all
goes flat so uh which sometimes does so
it's it's it's good
but you must be flat out because you've
also got yeah um grin's business yeah uh
unreal drink which has taken over the
rtd space in new zealand at the moment
mate how have you found that and how did
that one start
yeah i mean it has been yeah top time at
the moment isn't it precious the days of
uh
being able to go fishing and golfing
i've got to manufacture those again now
but um yeah but grinstein's been it's
been hectic it's
it's started off you know as erin does
you know sort of a couple of
conversations that you think won't
really eventuate um as you know
fully played we took a lot of rubbish at
times and nothing usually gets action
but uh we decided to go on one of these
sort of chats and uh and
dug a little deeper and got into it and
got to the point where we're too far in
now turn back and uh it's been it's been
awesome it's been all encompassing this
for sure it's been it's i guess it's
just been life for the last sort of
sort of seven or eight months really um
it's been pretty hectic but uh yeah it's
been it's been good fun and to do some
good good boys who uh
have some very interesting business
ideas at times that some of those um
it's uh it's been good yeah how how have
they been do they have much input into
the whole
setup of it and what's their what's
their role now in terms of what they do
uh we're very much in charge of the
departments they're in charge of
obviously social media um certainly
certainly wouldn't allow anton in charge
of budgeting or anything like that um
would already be under here in his way
i call him santa claus because he just
thinks we can give away everything um
but um now he's both they've been
brilliant like obviously all along said
to them boys you know it's what you can
what you can do is what you can do you
know like your bread and butter is your
footy and your mate that's your that's
your job at the moment so
flying event and all doing in the
background and you always helped out
where you can so they've been great um
they've been damien's obviously in japan
you know it's like when you're in
japanese apartment you've got a bit of
time on your hands so i'm probably
hearing i'm going to hear from him more
now than i probably will in the coming
years because uh once he's back here
getting his golf course again so
um but at the moment he's got plenty of
ideas and and the thing for all of us is
we're in a world now that we've got you
know we're literally learning as we go
yeah and uh and the good thing is i mean
we're going down it was always wide open
and you know every day you're like oh
it's interesting you know it's probably
common sense to people who have been in
it for years yeah but for us every day
we're like oh okay it's good to know so
yeah they've been great and it's uh yeah
who knows where it's gonna end up but
it's good fun yeah so have you got have
you got a plan going forward with it do
you have do you have a dream or where do
you see it in sort of five years time
oh man
i mean i've got i've got to tell you
i've got a business planner else you
know look like it is
salvage ramp
it's very fluid and i mean you know
anton's big on playing what he sees uh
so i guess grins will play what they see
in a lot of regards too but
you know we we've got to use i used to
be map out we've recently sort of mapped
out what we think the next year might
look like and then beyond that so
i mean in five years time if we're still
around
um it means we've been successful and
and we're still tracking so
i guess it's like you're fully creating
yeah people want to say you know what's
your five-year dream well if we're still
around in five years and i'm going right
sort of thing so i guess that's what
we're thinking as far as the uh with the
grins and uh
yeah hopefully hopefully we're not as
wet behind the ears in five years times
if we had been in the last six months
but i i guess what helps is that it goes
good it tastes tastes pretty good
everyone raves about it
yeah we're uh starting off you know when
you talk to people in the industry and
and around the place so marketing's a
big thing and you know obviously you
guys going to be able to get a leg up
with the profile of anton damien but at
the end of the day we could have
marketed it for a month or two but if it
tastes like rubbish you ain't gonna go
buy another one just because uh yeah
that's because the boys faces are there
so it was funny though makes me feel so
we tasted it we did the sampling in that
months and months before it actually
eventually went to stock i went to
stores and uh
the other boys were gone so it was just
me and uh me and sam went to the factory
at five o'clock in the morning before
the first run and they said oh you can
come at five o'clock in the morning
before we hit the go button on your
thousands and tens of thousands of cans
yeah um and just had one last sample and
it was the most nervous drink i've ever
had in my life um thinking geez i hope
we got this flavor right and uh
luckily i mean i'm i'm not the
target market anyway but uh i was like
no it's it'll do us and and lesh was
happy with it too so
we were up and running but uh i can tell
you mate they were too very new it's
been sitting in a manufacturing uh
warehouse at five o'clock in the morning
a few months ago thinking have we done
the right thing here
so are you a rtd man or are you still
still a classic beer man
oh look um probably
up until probably three months ago four
months ago i reckon i could have counted
on one hand how many
rtd's i've drunken in my life yeah um as
a youngster growing up had a crack on
kgbs and people go out and the parties
around waikiki but
woke up in the morning and i thought my
teeth were going to fall out so i stayed
away from them um and then obviously
being
why could i draft uh man i uh i didn't
have too much option for last 15 years
but
in the last three months i reckon i can
probably count on one hand how many
beers i've had and i'm just getting all
that
yeah and uh
and you know it's funny like obviously
your mates will get involved in it
because they want to you know support
their mate but uh i've got mates now who
i never thought i would ever see with a
yellow or an orange can in their hand
and uh
and that's what they buy so yeah i think
it's it's more socially acceptable now
for us kevin blake something to be
holding an rpd in our hands um
i mean i know i know the young
generation of damien and anton's things
don't even think twice about holding an
rtd but yeah for us all the ones but
it's uh it's been a bit of a shift well
i guess you're changing that stigma
because you are no one is one of the
manliest men around so seeing you hold
one i guess it makes it acceptable for
everyone
uh look if that's what it takes mate
they don't hold it many deleted
[Laughter]
oh mate but exciting times ahead for
grins but we do have a hell of a journey
to get through uh yours is one of the
greats so i do want to start at the
start as a as a young baby beaver what
was that like
um oh just like i guess every sort of
other kiwi kid you know growing up and
you know not not the big cities um just
ripping into everything and
played every sport going
um put a fair bit of time then into
tennis um
played all the regional staff and
national stuff with that um
and then sort of got to age about 14 and
15 realized i was going to win wimbledon
um so so started to park they parked
their um idea and
how's your back
what how'd you be
i reckon uh well a few things a back end
would have been helpful
you need more than a first serve and a
wayward forehand to uh
but um
and to be fair like
um sort of
and it's funny when you think about it
because obviously you shouldn't be
making your sporting career as a 10 year
old but sort of 10 or 11 you're sort of
competing with everyone and then
everyone at that age i guess in the big
smoke just from that age was just 12
months a year tennis and i would just
park it for six months play club footy
like junior boys footy and then come
back to it when it was time to try and
make the nationals and qualif qualify
for the teams events and stuff like that
and uh by the time i was i was 12 you
sort of you're almost out the rear so
it just became a time thing and uh and
as i say a lack of a back end um
probably was also very significant in
that and is that when rugby took over
no i wouldn't say took over like um i
mean like you don't have the german
being all black but um
i still played about a sport down there
and got into cricket then started
playing a little bit of
rip cricket and stuff
um and then flagged that when i uh was
playing cricket on saturday we played
rip on sunday and then get a duck on a
sunday and work out what have i just
given up my entire weekend for this um
you know it's gonna be a bit away so
i think i think the rugby obviously
always had the dream and then sort of
um when i got to about 15 or 16 started
to i used to
do the
i got i remember getting given a
acc used to put out a training program
i just remember getting this it was just
a generic one and i remember getting
there so i was kidding
i mean a bit compulsive and uh on it one
summer and i went from being an absolute
slug to someone with a little bit of toe
and all of a sudden the following year
sort of 17
16 17 rugby became a little bit i guess
in your local area it became a little
bit easier and started making making the
rip team you know pretty comfortably and
stuff and then was like oh okay and then
sort of
obviously making the decision to then go
to wesley
um
really i just kick-started it all really
properly yeah how hard was that move
yeah massive massively hard um obviously
a wiki boy thrown through
and uh
weasley although at the time were
probably the undisputed kings of um
secondary school rugby in new zealand um
didn't really have any thought of ever
going there um
jerome and johnny farah and joe rocks
who were all counties boys before they
signed the big checks to go to st kent
um
they they'd always sort of
sort of talked to their their people at
saint kents and and tried to get me up
there and then in my 7th form year i was
like you know what maybe it was time to
investigate this bit further so
went up there talked to them um the
scholarships and all that were gonna be
sorted um but then
they sort of said oh look because
there's so many imports now in our
school um you're probably gonna start
out a second to fan all this sort of
thing and then
county's got a hold of me and sid and i
and counties haven't really shown a
whole lot of love apart from by just
your normal age cube stuff and uh they
said i would just consider going to
weasley and staying around counties
and i was like
it's uh it's about left field but uh
in the end uh my old man teaches their
work at college which made it even
tougher like he was all for it but um
he obviously it was difficult but
the funniest thing was the year before
we played them
uh
and uh
we had been quite a fire encounter and
once they died got on the bottom of iraq
and
it turned into an all-including the
sideline and uh i was the target of it
and uh then i was
turned around on day one and then uh
a couple of them were covered in the
fijian boys and obviously when i got the
weasley ceremony sort of instantly
became best mate
and i could sense it was i could since
there was a yard just floating around
this crew because the fijians always
hung together and i'd always hang with
them and then about a week into silly
just brought it up and said you know
those two there
they beat you up last year and uh
because i couldn't remember who was but
so
yeah once we got past that and uh i love
my time there um and it kick-started
everything really as far as all of a
sudden um
counties
counties pulled me out of class one day
and said uh you're playing this weekend
for counties um show up the training on
thursday sort of thing so
um there was i used from my childhood or
not
your teenage years that was probably the
thing that really kick-started
everything and uh we're going to be
forever grateful of the time there mate
that's crazy that counties called you
out of your classroom so did you know
did you expect that had you been
training with them at all or where did
this come from
no it was oh and uh because i as soon as
i got to wesley i ended up getting
stress fracture on my back because i had
no idea about i had no idea about doing
weights but i thought oh well i better
start doing weights and they had a gym
there but none of the other boys needed
to use them so i just went in there in
my lunch time and started
i mean i'm not the most coordinated
thing anyway but me doing weights the 16
or 17 year old no wonder i got stress
fractures um
and so no i didn't even play the first
part of the year and then i was
literally walking between classes and i
heard my name over the loudspeaker
reports the principal's office
and the county's officials are in there
and they said look uh we talked to your
dad this morning we've cleared it with
him um if you can come to training and
you're away and um
it was i mean it was
well there was nobody near i should have
been there um can't even saw first
version at the time and
um i ended up sitting on the bench for
about four or five games that yeah yeah
it was just it was it was crazy like i'd
literally get told i was never i was
never there other than a thursday
afternoon training your final training
right
and they'll say well come on in and okay
yep we're playing auckland we can't walk
out of this week you're on the bench and
i'm like well i've got no idea what's
going on here i'm literally i'm
literally 60 kgs dripping wet here um
and that's when the all blacks all
played npc so you can imagine being a 17
year old just like well yeah what were
the guys like um when you went into the
environment were they all welcoming or
were they pretty um tough work for a
young school kid
it was still about like proper old
school era um but um i was lucky there's
a couple guys from waiku in there
and there was because i was at wesley
there's a couple of weasley guys in
there so he sort of had he sort of had a
bit of a cushioning um
yeah i mean
to be fair though probably pretty good
it was probably
a more welcoming area of welcoming team
then maybe if you've gone into one of
the like the big guns yeah um
but
i mean yeah when you look back now it's
just like jeez
what was that what was going on
and how did you go how did you go on the
field when you got a crack
uh i remember my first game uh bae
plenty dropped the first pass i got um
so that's good um
good confidence booster good confidence
booster tracked off the field thinking
well that was my one and only
um
lockheed croydon went down
after about 30 minutes against
canterbury at pookie stadium and this is
the day after we just won the top 32
final for wesley and they said oh they
wrote me up after the game from the
change room they said oh tomorrow can
you come in and play for us i haven't
heard from them for a couple weeks
and so
i'm sitting on the bench there and then
lockheed's going down i was like oh no
and this has been canterbury had about
17 current all backs not so hot
no lucky shake it off please shake it
off
um but he went off and i'm out there i'm
thinking geez i'm going to play 50
minutes here or whatever it was and uh
started to starts enjoyed and a few
things started to go my way and then
thankfully lockheed got a jab that's
been jabs under the under the shed we're
all going and uh he got one he came back
out of he was very good to me lucky i
mean he's i think he knew he was a 17
year old outfit while he was dead out
there but he
oh that's good stuff and i i i vividly
remember actually ball boying you it
must have been the following year when
you were playing against nelson base
you must have been really young
obviously you were you year out of
school but i must have been quite an old
ball boy too now that i think about it
i vividly remember
handing you the tea and you
acknowledging me like not many guys
would acknowledge you when you give them
the tea that you you made an effort and
changed my life
yeah most second division rock stars
mate they didn't always say thank you
well what was it like going down to that
competition probably felt more um in
your
skill level i guess
yeah no it was good because like you
know
and it's interesting about when you're
going to run now like whether you'd
still do that sort of thing but like
alright two years down there and i still
think that was
more beneficial for me than going and
playing
colts or whatever it was in one of the
big unions because
you're playing grand men um you're
playing for a team that if you play
poorly for if you walk down the street
after a game you'll hear about it still
so it's a bit of a hardening up process
in that regards like people care about
the success of
providence and counties or whatever
um so
hands like back then
yeah nelson hawke's favor on another
level to most um so it was sort of
hawke's bay and then there was nelson
bay's ass um mana with two all sort of
scrapping around that that second sort
of posse area yeah and uh it was good
footy like uh i always loved coming down
there on the hard track and uh it was
good fun footy and with sidovini
obviously in our team so yeah i'll just
cut out to him and we'll just hope the
best really
so then why the move to waikato
oh back then it just i mean
back then bases
the super bases
were at npc level were the base of the
of the franchise and
it was i mean i don't think i'm giving
away any great secret that if you play
for an mpc team in one of those bases
the odds are you were going to get
picked for the super team yeah so um i'm
glad to see where it's at now like you
can literally as you say you can play
for a mark or you can play for counties
and you can be anywhere but back then um
it was just the way that
npc teams could recruit for their what
sorry super saiyans could recruit for
mvc teams and it was corrupt
but
that's the way it was so i knew i had to
get to a base to get to super and it
pretty much came down to waikato or
otago and
otago had been knocking on the door for
probably since the moment uh finished
school at wesley
and so did one today but um otago would
probably had sort of winked and nudged
and said oh look if you come down you'll
get super probably a year earlier
um but then i and i stubbornly said oh
well pick me and i'll come down um
and they went another way
so um i never went in the ends but um in
the end why can't i was at the time it
was more of a case of you know i'm still
pretty
pretty green little boy and it's only an
hour and a half from home and
hamilton seemed like a massive city to
me anyway or any city new zealand seemed
like a massive city to me so
it was just a nice sort of safe option i
think um
and i think you know i talked dad
obviously
had a fair bit of you know thought about
it all he's fought though there's
probably a quicker route to being the
starting team you know there than a few
of the other places and um they sort of
hit david hill at the time and glenn
jackson had moved on to bay of plenty
and then off to overseas so
that was going to be the quicker route
we sort of thought about and uh and in
the end it worked out um
and yeah it was a
massive part of my life being a vulu man
yeah and how was it how was how was
living in hamilton how was playing for
waikato
yeah i mean i remember my first week
down there um was oh week and i remember
vividly being in the outback on about
two o'clock in the morning it was a
monday tuesday and just looking at
myself saying what am i doing where am i
where can i be at two o'clock in the
morning on a monday you know like i'm
coming from somewhere where you just uh
friday and saturdays are your only
options but uh i was just getting caught
in the bright lights of the tron from
day one
but then yeah no i mean once i got
settled in and got into my routine um
again living with citovini which was
again a great experience for me me and
my
schoolmate we lived the first couple
years together so
um yeah
hamilton i love hamilton i know a lot of
people
who've never experienced hamilton have
no time for it but
um oh it's a great city and uh
you know the people the people there
were always wonderful to me and
you know i wouldn't wouldn't change it
for the world yeah what was sadavini
like to live with
uh look
um
well what can i say uh
there wasn't a whole lot of uh
well in
waikato's
smartness i guess they employed a
cleaner and who i think was only
supposed to come once every fortnight
she ended up coming i think twice weekly
um
there was
i remember
glenn ross who was in charge of us at
the time um he came to us and said boys
i got an issue
i was like what he goes oh we've got a 3
000 heating bill for you
and that was more than what i was on
from white kiddo so
and ross so i looked at ross and go well
he's got super rugby already all right
i've got no money i'm not paying a 3000
but city obviously couldn't yeah
it was like an incubator our house every
heater in the uh in the rooms were on
and uh
it was just uh it was a sauna um and a
messy sauna at that but um
i mean
red city go back a long way so it was uh
apart from all that it was great times
yeah um and then he quickly earned a lot
of money so he ended up buying his own
mentions though i just i caught up some
of my mates from back home and started
playing with him over and uh hillcrest
so yeah
and on the field how did how was it on
the field you obviously that's when your
famous stephen donald show and go was
introduced to new zealand
every second carrie
one of the great show and goes
yeah i mean it's uh
it was amazing like my first year of
waikato john mitchell was our head coach
oh yeah
and he had literally just come from
the year before
being the all black coach
and so like it's it was just like you
were just in the days every day you went
to training and like
mitch bought the same organization and
the same i guess
trimmings around the team that you'd
expect the all rex to have and like the
computer work and
how he structures work and all the
themings and i was just like i'd come
from second division counties and i was
thinking sheepish you know what i've
walked into here it was so good
it's been hours with you
go into depth like
the likes of what she had never seen
before i think he probably made his own
sort of computer analyzing program you
know he was it was that engrossed in it
so
and that was great for me and then
following on from that got super rugby
they played a few got a few starts for
white going into that year and i think
we bowed out in the city and wellington
um but yeah
it was it was a great time and then to
get the super on the back of it when
i knew i was i knew i was on the cusp of
it but back then it was only 26 players
get the contract so
he was still a real nervous nervous wait
for i think they used to have a draft
day in october hi at the end of the
scene just sitting by your phone
thinking is this the year because i've
been for the first the last couple years
of being in the pool but obviously never
getting packed so
um that was
that was an experience to wait for
finally get the uh get the go ahead with
the chiefs but and then obviously
just goes again to start as a
professionalism and hearing from there
so
um now those early years it's almost
like just in the days anyways
you're just a kid still and you just
you know what's what you just gotta well
i've gotta be at training at eight
o'clock and you're just following the
find the path from there
and how did you find out that you got
drafted was that how did that thing work
well it's funny uh the the previous
years when i was so caught in contention
for the chiefs and these other places um
i got rang by you know the assistant
coach or the manager or whatever but the
year that they picked me fozzie wrote me
up and said oh we're going to take you
this year oh yeah
that's good
i remember because i was about to go
play touch up home and have a bit of a
thursday night and he said oh you got to
be down here at 9 o'clock tomorrow for a
press conference
like yeah i'll be there i'll be there
but
i don't want to shape off being possible
[Laughter]
and what memories stand out for you from
your chief's days
um
oh i guess
i used the
the group that we had to be fair like in
like we were we were inconsistent as
buggery especially for a lot of those
early years um and just
we
it's not like we tried to but you could
almost put a clock to it that would lose
our first three or four games
and then and then we'd just catch a
light and we would almost be unbeatable
for the rest of it but when you're
playing stupid 12
sometimes
the playoffs were even gone and you and
you couldn't make it even if you won
your last seven or eight because we'd
already dropped our first three or four
and so i just remember like the days of
once we finally caught caught a light it
was just so easy playing with illuakies
and you know yeah you loose forwards for
me because we just had a pretty simple
game plan would get over your varnish on
out wide with you know a city or
something like that
and then you just come back into the
midfield and then you'll have a little
archive holding on and we'll just play
off the back of that yeah
and that was that was pretty cool and
obviously no nine we went
all the way to the final and then just
uh had an absolute disaster in pretoria
but again you know at the start you
talked about
um
the ride and all the rest of it playing
the final in pretoria you know like yeah
it would have been great to won it don't
get me wrong but
experiencing playing the blue balls and
loftus for final is uh something else um
i mean anyone that's played them we know
when they were rocking and rolling and
they had the whole springbok team pretty
much it was uh it was an experience like
nothing else um from the moment you lead
your hotel to the moment you get out
there yeah
quite incredible so those were probably
it and then
i guess the second stint coming back um
i didn't know what i was walking into i
didn't know how much fun it would be but
it was oh
yeah i'm just so glad that i ended up
taking the punt on that and doing it
yeah
and uh
yeah just
coming back and knowing that you're
going to be a contender every year
because that's what they've built on the
rings um was pretty special and then
obviously the group there was a fairly
decent
group of guys but also footballers as
well so
i mean the chiefs for me just it's just
always been just
awesome buggers to hang out with and uh
and guys are gonna front and
you know some years it works out better
than others but uh yeah just
just a special special time in our lives
again yeah good times so going back to
your first stint with the chiefs your
form was obviously good enough to get
your call into the all blacks was that
expected when that came or
how did that one come about
um well yeah i mean i guess after a
couple of years there i started to think
it must be knocking on the door and the
year before i actually got picked i was
i went down to a training camp that they
tried to keep under wraps yeah before
world cup where ocean woke up and they
um
i remember looking around and i was the
only one there because dc was still over
with the crusaders they were still
making their way back from africa and uh
and milzy my great mate who was
obviously a senior pro at the time he
was like oh you're in you got me
training camp in wellington um
and uh i think i've butchered every one
of uh smoothies uh y-line drills um so i
don't know i don't know if i cost my
world cup selection then and there but i
probably could have found it
um
and then they they sit up they told us
after um or if you get a phone call
tonight it's not good news but if not
it's all good tomorrow morning sort of
thing
and uh
mel's he knew i was in an absolute uh
jittering mess uh so he took me out for
dinner and it started to get to about 9
30 and i'm like wow
tim would be in bed by now surely i'd
have been caught by that
unfortunately sitting in a japanese
restaurant he gave me a drink call but i
wasn't going to be picked so
um yes it was that was i guess that's
what probably all of a sudden gave me
thought that
it could happen yeah uh getting that
close obviously it was heartbreak but
in retrospect there's no way i was going
to be ready for that
uh
the 07 world cup quarter final if i'd
been thrown out there i know i'd been a
fan to a supporter i think but
um i think yeah the following year
obviously it was very much in your
thought process that
this is what i'm working towards and i
must be pretty close after the previous
year
and then yeah just uh again there's a
training camp at the end of super rugby
and again you're not trying to get too
excited because been down this fruit
before back then
then they uh listened to the radio uh
one sunday morning uh
did uh well not he didn't read it out
but um yeah someone read it out and it
was in there crazy and did you feel good
enough once you were named and once
you're in that environment did you feel
ready to be in all black
yeah i mean i i i guess you
when you're looking around and you know
you like think well obviously dc aside
then you think yep i deserve to be here
but i guess because it's all you've ever
wanted and that it took a i don't know
when i even felt comfortable in there or
if i ever did you know
it was probably so surreal to me that it
been your dream all those years
that you know like as soon as you get in
there they talk about oh be a great all
black blah blah blah and then you're
thinking well oh hang on no you've got
burtons and spencer and fox and all that
when you were growing up they were great
all blacks oh i'm nowhere near it
um so just you know funny things like
that i remember sticking your head in
it took um
yeah i reckon like i didn't really think
i was an all black until we played
um
the trinity it ended up being a try
nation's inventors load decider in
brisbane
and um
they
crazily took maher off
uh was about 20 to go when we were down
by about fifth oh no we're down what
about eight or nine yeah and they
chucked me out there i remember pulling
mar off and said oh baby you're right
i'm saying
me for me
we need points what are you bringing me
on for
but uh they bumped dizzy out and and we
got and we got the result in the end and
uh
i think there was eight or nine games in
to i guess the career of
plans for the all blacks it was that
night sitting back in hotels when i
actually felt like an all that because
the rest of them were all sort of those
cameos when the job was done and you
know like yeah it was nice to be kept or
rest but it was 10 minutes on the field
when we were already up by 15 or what
have you so i guess that was the night
that for me it was almost like my debut
where i actually felt like a genuine all
black and it contributed to i guess a
tough situation
and i feel like not many people got um
the public scrutiny that you did
throughout your career and did you feel
like that even at this stage when you
were playing well and um you were you
you were in just come into the all
blacks
yeah i mean yeah i did and uh like i
tried to block myself off from it but i
guess there's that constant feeling of
like a lot of the times i was like are
you kidding me um like you know i
thought i'd play well enough in super
for
you know a few years and whenever it was
npc time you'd go back and play well
there but yeah it was it was constant
almost having to prove myself that you
know i am the second best team in this
country
and
yeah it was well it did get a little bit
frustrating after a while but well he's
it added to it helped me in a lot of
ways because it just constantly added a
chip to my shoulder
and trying to prove people wrong but at
times it would have been good to have
been out of focus your energy elsewhere
um
but yeah but then it all spiraled even
worse at her uh after that hong kong uh
game obviously lot's been talked about
that but how'd you feel after that night
yeah i mean
yeah all been i walked off the field
knowing that i played poorly um
and you know made a couple of
just really annoying because it just
come back in the nbc had four or five
good weeks there and was feeling in a
real good good space and we'd have an
internal game and that went real well
and
just getting up to hong kong 20 minutes
to go i mean they chucked me out there
and just made a real few poor decisions
um and then at the end of the day missed
the gold kick that could have probably
smuggled over a few of the decisions
that i made the goal could be you'd
usually bank on getting sort of 14 15
from touch 21 hour
you nail that and the game's buried yeah
puts out eight points as opposed to five
um and and all the other stuff would
have just become sort of quickly
forgotten about but um
unfortunately missed that
and then
missed the touch and then all of a
sudden you know it kind of kicks it from
the sideline
and just yeah it was just a
brutal part of i guess real part of the
job and you know like
one because you can lock yourself away
when you're touring and you know social
media was a thing then but it wasn't
massive so
i wasn't on it and i didn't need to be
on it and i was then all sudden i was
getting messages from my mates back home
who weren't rugby mate so i just
mentioned back home and they were saying
hang in there boys sort of thing and
you're like you wouldn't even text me
that what's going on and uh and that's
when i was like starting to think geez
what's what's been there i know i've
played poorly and we've lost the test
and all the rest of it but obviously
that sort of was a
i used an introduction to what the uh
what the aftermath was going to be and
then once i got back to new zealand it
just continued and over summer it
continued and
um and then all through super whenever
we weren't playing at hamilton it just
continued and
it just uh it just wore i used something
to warm me down a fair bit um and
probably had a fair bit in the decision
to sign of bath you know because i mean
i never dreamed of
going overseas and playing rugby to make
money i just dreamed of being an all
black so
i was never going to
walk away from that if i thought it was
still a possibility but
the way it was unfolding and
the news i was
sort of starting to get filtered back
from the top i sort of knew that the all
black days were
done um so
that's that's yeah that's the only
reason the english sign of bath um
yeah so how hard was it was it when you
were going out like could you go out in
public or were you just constantly
copying it
yeah constantly like um i pretty much
wouldn't go out um
if i went out i'd go out on a mine that
i wouldn't actually be able to remember
what you told me so that's not a good
state to go at it yeah but that was
probably that was probably a couple of
times during super rugby
when i sort of needed a blowout um
and then
yes going to the supermarket and stuff
like that was i guess at night time with
your hoodie on sort of thing it was just
very much from house to house to
training training to home and
and just sort of track through it
because
it was just yeah it was just getting to
a point where it's like you couldn't
couldn't avoid it um
so it was just it was a funny old time
but um yeah i mean
now you look back and just go oh
again it's glad it happened but um
yeah at the time it was a fairly dark
sort of dark sort of uh eight or nine
months
that's crazy so when the world cup squad
was selected you were never expecting to
make it
now
tim had rung me up probably a few weeks
beforehand
and he you know
i can't remember too much what he said
because in those conversations yeah as
soon as you've heard what you've not
wanted to hear
you've you've switched off and and it's
probably more for their benefit than
anything
um so i mean you just said saying like
you're not going to be there or best in
bath
thanks for last few years sort of thing
um so now i went out of the picture um
never got told that oh yeah you're this
in line you're this in line it was you
know just enjoy bath and
um and be on your way pretty much and
what point did you start thinking hang
on i might be getting called in here
well no oil
um he messaged me after he messaged me
after um
yes the one and only uh he messaged me
after dc's groin and he goes get ready
boy get ready and i was uh i remember
where i was when it was ringing and i
was like no mate because they took
they'd actually taken cruds to a
training camp
so
and
cruds
you know i had a good npc too so there
was no reason to think that they changed
their thinking there so
obviously um
about a day later after cahoot tried to
tell me i was coming in
they'd already got cruds in there um so
now and to be honest if you're like
because petty you've been doing a lot of
goal kicking and and things like that
and he'd sort of take a more senior role
in it all
um
i remember watching uh the quarter final
i think it was probably the first all
that game i've had in the next watch
when um slade went down yeah and i was
like oh well
i'm still i'm under no
no illusions that i've i've been told
anything um so i don't have any great
hopes here so
just jumped i had well i'd already had
plans to go wipe out the next day and it
was already having to get up it's sort
of sparrow so i was like well i'm still
going because
i've i'm under no reason to think any
otherwise and i told tahui don't you
bloody rang me
[Laughter]
and uh and then he's texting me that
night saying
shaggs just talked to me what are you up
to and i said i still don't take this as
anything other than your rubbish chat
um so then yeah and obviously as the
story goes it wasn't until late that
next afternoon after we got off the
river that i had even thought that it
was gonna happen
true that's crazy and then how quickly
did you have to be in the squad
uh the next day because they played the
day before so giving everyone a day off
and then
they weren't training bugger all anyway
by that stage yeah because so that's
outside beaten up so i remember at
grandma's birthday that night so i had
grandma's birthday and then because i
was carlos because uh they all blacks
had taken my car off me
i'd actually had i'd actually have carol
his car for the previous six months and
uh he said i'll come back because i was
up home in waiakea he said come back to
hamilton and we'll drive up tomorrow
together
and i was like that's a good idea so i
went back to hamilton
came back with cox and uh a bit nervous
obviously we stop at the uh huntley
yelling it's a shell station there at
huntley and um
he uh goes and puts petrol in the diesel
ute so we're not being about two hours
late for when i was supposed to be in
there because we're waiting for you to
get pumped out
so but my sweaty palms have just gone
absolutely
berserk waiting to get to the hotel now
and it's uh
it's got even more awkward showing up
late to my first day back in there they
probably didn't bank on him to call me
up anyway yeah just made it a little bit
more awkward oh man that's crazy and how
did you feel had you been doing any
training did you feel did you feel ready
to give it a crack or were you a little
bit
are you a little bit
over it you know
oh like i was it's funny because some
people say oh did you think about saying
no i was like no
no um it's what you always craved but as
far as conditioning goes we'd finish the
npc about seven weeks earlier we lost
the final and i had in my mind um that
you know i was going to be missing
everything about new zealand for two
three years was my contract to bath so i
was just gonna try and pack him into
that six six weeks
so
i had uh why didn't he be six weeks uh
and i remember cuck's telling me he goes
you should start doing some training for
bathroom yeah
and my motivation for bath at the time
was about that so i was like man it's a
guaranteed contract who cares what shape
or sharpening um so
no i showed up in some pretty rough
shape to the oblique environment to be
fair uh i remember going to see that
guild with trainer at the time and
obviously worked for the chiefs i said
man i'm not in great shape um
what can i do when you go snow you'll be
right you got you've got a good engine
um
just do a bit of sharpening work during
the week if you want
so
yeah i mean you don't even
i mean you pride yourself on your
fitness all your career and then the
most famous game you're playing you're
completely overweight people telling you
how fat you were so it's um
it was a bit of a bit of a kick in the
guts but anyway hey that's so good at so
good so did you
did you still feel confident in your
skill set and stuff to be playing in a
world cup final
yeah obviously you don't really think
about it but yeah
the good thing the good thing about
going into the campus because i guess
when you think you're never going to go
back again you have a few sleepless
nights thinking where did i let this all
slip yeah and i had plenty of those
nights from hong kong onwards and a lot
of it was around like
i i would play a certain way for a while
and chase which was very simplistic but
then when i'd gone to the all blacks i'd
you know i'd complicate things and and
try and do stuff you know like dc for
example had the greatest kicking game
i've ever seen yeah
and you know i'd go in there and
obviously the all blacks had these
kicking calls for that kick that kept
that kick and i'm like
okay um uh i'm i've got to produce that
too do i
you know you beat yourself to the pulp
trying to train and get it there but you
know like
as we all know i'm not the most fluid
and gifted sort of athlete in that
regard but he could just drop it on a
drop on a five cent piece so
i guess the good thing about all of that
experience was
when i got caught back and i was like
right i'm going to go in there i'm going
to do this this that and that's all i'm
going to do and um you know
that was probably the thing that held me
in good mindset for you know having not
touched the footy for about six weeks
the fact that i wasn't going to go in
there and try and change the world
um was good and to be fair with coaches
for actually and it's probably the first
time the coaches were similar on that
they're like right just do what are you
what are you two good kicks i was like
long high
and uh
and those were going to be my two kicks
going into the game so
um you know just stuff like that oh i
think you know in hindsight i wish i'd
done that from day dot in the door but
uh might not have to go through all the
other stuff but
yeah it was
it was it was a good way to probably go
in there just to
keep it simple i've got these two kicks
i'll run harder
if there's a dummy if there's a chance
to dummy show and go and i wasn't just
gonna
nice and when you got the call on the
bench how was the heart
yeah i was like i was sitting there
thinking
crazy crowds would want to stop surely
mean almost a note
because there's that moment that he got
up and i was looking at the big screen
and looked like he was going to shake it
off and then he stands up and then this
the medico sort of let him stand on his
own two feet and then he sort of just
collapses on that knee i'm like
we're into it now yeah so i mean you
know like
it's yeah the heart was gone but at the
end of the day
for 10 months after hong kong it was the
moment you never thought you were gonna
get again
so
it was just something that you were back
oh yes
there's a chip on your shoulder um and
your event sort of focused on
taking full advantage you know like a
lot of a lot of stuff had been said and
carried on about me in that ten months
so
i had 40 or 50 minutes to try and try
and uh wash that all the way really yeah
and when that penalty went they point
point to the post mate i loved how
confidently you just straight up to the
spot with the kicking tee were you
feeling that confident
uh yeah i mean it's it's one of those
ones that it was actually probably
pretty fortunate that there's one that
in my routine my general training
routine that is that's one of the ones i
always sort of have in my having my uh
session yeah and so you know you put
that over a million times and you know
um i knew you know like
it should be bread and butter and you
know
at the time i wasn't thinking that this
could change everything which if i had
it probably would have shank and then
come off the spinner
um you know
it was just a kick that had to go over
so
um it was good i had nick byrne on the t
who was always a good sounding board for
me around my kicking stuff anyway yeah
and i told him before the game look
because he whenever i got myself into
trouble as far as goal kicking-wise it
was always if i speed things up
and and speeding things up like you you
set up your routine and everything so
i just have to make you made if you
bring em tea up to me just tell me to be
slow and it probably still wasn't that
slow because probably the heart was
probably going 100 miles an hour but at
least in my mind i was thinking slow
yeah
um so yeah and then apparently it snuck
in i never saw it go over but apparently
snacking right in upright and when you
hit it did you think it was over
straight away yeah because that's why i
always always start mine sort of a meter
in from that um right hand upright and
they never go they never go right i need
to have a fade on it and so i hit it saw
it yep happy
charged back and then uh wasn't until
later on that night after we could all
relax that few people were like you know
it only just went over right
what do you mean and they go start to go
out right
[Laughter]
but what about the rest of your game did
you ever review that game how did you
feel you went
no i mean
all i remember is we had to make a
million tackles yeah
and that's i guess that was that was a
cool thing like it was one of those ones
that you really had to earn
and
you know like of anyone that knows me
knows i've never really enjoyed uh the
defensive aspect of the game um but that
night you sort of did because you just
felt so secure
um with a bunch of dudes also that you'd
spend a lot of time with and you're good
mates with so you know yeah
it's the quietest mar's ever been using
mar's got plenty of lip for me but he
was that tired he couldn't talk too much
but it was just literally just looking
at each other yeah and you sort of knew
that
got my side covered i've got your inside
covered and it was just one of those
nights and
um to do effect sort of group and you
know been for a bit worth it was uh it
was pretty cool but yeah as far as the
game goes it probably would have been a
great watch um but uh it was it was a
nice sort of way to win it i reckon
and what were the celebrations like post
world cup success at home must have been
one of the great nights
yeah it was funny uh again i remember
mick boone coming to me
who knew me well um he came to me
probably about oh because we said in the
[ __ ] because it's such such a late game
um i think it was a nine o'clock kickoff
we stayed in the shed till i think two
ish oh sure we're gonna get back to the
hotel into the three and i remember
coming to many games um because he's
probably he sensed that i could really
enjoy this um he said look uh we're
gonna have a few days of this just
saving us and you want you want to take
all this in
and so i mostly i mostly took that on
board um and i did and i did take it
pretty easy for a long time and then
um got whistled down i think uh what the
a lot of the sponsors had hired our big
apartments down in the viaduct yeah i
mean i ended up down there with milsie
smoking cigars or something georgie
grigg and i think
probably
tennis
in the morning there and then then we
get a tip saying well you better get
we'll get back to the uh hotel we've got
a team meeting in the uh
a team meeting in the um team room to
get organized for these um
these parades
and so you're you're walking in there
thinking like jesus i'm going to be able
to sort of try and scrub myself but
scrub yourself up here and you walk and
then there's obviously just
bins and bins of the sponsors the
sponsor's finest and uh in a few clean
polo shirts and uh sunglasses
but it hasn't made um you don't really
get you know like the objects obviously
you go on any of your tours and you get
it one day
or one night somewhere where you can
really let your hair down but
the cool a lot of the the best parts of
that whole experience was
having that three days where we stayed
as a team and then we went around the
countryside
where there was no next game to prepare
for although there was no chat of ice
baths or recovery and there you know you
just really enjoyed it and like yeah
they were big nights but it was just
more being with a group that you spend
so much time with but never really had
those sort of moments with and uh yeah
the best night by far was coming back uh
we'd been down to christchurch and
obviously that was the terrible year
that christchurch had so there's no
accommodation for us after that
and then the next day was in wellington
and uh
again we get a text saying oh come to
the team room guys put a bit of food on
for you blah blah and everyone's pretty
jaded by the stage and you're walking
there and they'd set it up like a bar
and there was there's djs setups and
honestly hands down the greatest one of
the greatest nights of life and
i'm thinking about i think about four
o'clock in the morning we decided to go
hit wellington on a monday night there
wasn't a whole lot going on but uh it
was still
still again just a special time and uh
yeah got for another parade there and i
think when we went to hit office before
the parade
i i think hit office
made the mistake of rolling out some
some of uh steinlag's finest too and
i don't think the boys need much topping
up and i think a few of them
and chile were thinking uh what have we
done here these boys got to go on a
parade
so how did your life change that we'll
post that world cup
um oh i mean yeah there's a whole lot of
stuff
i guess float on the back of it and i've
got a job now that probably doesn't
happen if the world cup doesn't happen
but yeah um
for me it was more a case of getting
your life back you know like talked
about then start how
you know you didn't want to go to pub
going to public and you know you're
constantly
looking at people thinking what do you
think of me or you know like what are
you saying behind my back sort of thing
um to you know not you know just getting
getting a relaxedness about relaxedness
if that's a word um just back in your
life you know and just being able to
enjoy life again um and yeah like this
big stuff sort of flowed from that you
know which would have never happened
otherwise which has been great but
that's just all the
trimmings on top really the for the guts
of it for me was just getting your life
back really and you know getting life
back from the family and then and
and a big thing too i use which i just
graded me a little bit was being proud
to be like proud to be all back again
yeah
for you know like you know when you hear
bits and pieces about i don't deserve to
be all black and all the rest of it
you're like you know that cat's pretty
big
so i think being proud of being able to
achieve what we did and bounce back from
i guess the horror of it was hong kong
100 and one of those trimmings you talk
about was the movie a movie about your
life mate what sort of an input did you
put on that
uh i had a the the movie place actually
strange enough got makoni to come
interview me for the best part about
eight hours um
and so he came and interviewed me and
they and he then gave them all that
information
and then
they obviously
just went off and wrote their movie and
uh
and then sent us a few scripts and we're
like oh come on this is this is to
hollywood
and they're like no no no so at the end
of the day um because people ask you how
true's
how how close is that well the guts of
it is the outline of it is pretty much
bang on and then obviously there's all
the gst sprinkled on top pretty much so
um
but yeah
it was a situation where it got rang up
about when i was in bath by simon my
manager and he said hey they want to do
a movie about you i said what he said
yeah
and he said i said to him do you reckon
what happened and he goes nah i probably
won't will that okay
so what should i say to him i'll say yes
but it's not going to happen and then
two months later we get running up oh
that moves happening by the way
were you happy with the guy who played
you
did a good job dave yeah david like i
mean admittedly i've only watched it
once and uh i watched it today but it
came well david was on one and
admittedly i might not have been or
i prepared myself for it so i was pretty
dusty and uh
i can't recall a whole movie but um
for everyone that's watched that says
who knows me he did a good job of taking
me off and i had a couple quite a couple
of nights with him and that prior to him
doing his acting and stuff so
um yeah it's good you're a good fella um
but uh yeah
i i guess i guess the kids will watch it
one day um but uh yeah it's uh
andrew interesting to see you being you
know a feature of a movie it's uh quite
a bizarre
quite a bizarre situation yeah there's
some crack up lookalikes in there
some of the characters
oh hardcase
for some of some of them rifle were
absolutely accurate and then some of
them some of the people who the actual
people in real life were quite disgusted
have you looked in the mirror
oh but you touched on your move to bath
and why you did it um how did you how
did you find it once you got over there
yeah it's a funny one like um
i
i guess for bath the club the worst
thing to happen was probably the world
cup final because you know like all of a
sudden the reason i went there
was no longer a reason and i wish i was
you know like i i did bring my agent off
you know
furiously for a couple of days after the
finals said come on let's i'll stay i'll
stay i don't need to go now i can stay
sort of thing yeah and he's oh go go i
need my commission go
um
so i went and you know like
bath was fast great city um
but you know like they were a club at
the time who
i think they were they were trying to
find themselves like they got a
billionaire owner who was
more worried probably about
he he bought this estate and decided
that that's where they're going to be
based and like that's great but you know
like there's a whole lot of other stuff
that is more important than this
and it was just it was just a bit showy
um
one of the worst things that happened to
me is my first week out there was uh
european cup games and i was excited
because i was like well i signed a bath
over a couple other teams because they
were in europe and i thought well i'd
get bored out of my brain just playing
premiership rugby a week and week out
but they're in europe so it looks cool
um
went up there and the the foreign boys
got a hold of me on tuesday and said
because my partner didn't come up with
partner at that time didn't come up
until months after and they said i'll
we'll take you out for a feed i was oh
yes sweet
and they took me out and all of a sudden
i realized this feed was not gonna be
just a uh bit of sushi and home
pretty quickly so
we went out and had about a four or five
o'clock out on the tuesday leading in
the montpellier in the european cup
and uh
i could i woke up and i was right
where's the nearest sauna um i wasn't a
frenzy i think what sort of preparations
this
we went out we beat montpellier and uh i
get me on the match and i'm like well
you know what maybe i can enjoy myself
over here and still play half even fully
and uh
we uh me and because of the south
african boys were like oh well i guess
we repeat the dose this week do we so we
went out did the same lost oh well we'll
try it again went out did the same don't
work so
i guess i got into a real false sense of
uh what it was going to be like but um
no i mean i
i i probably
like at the time i think because
you know i guess i ticked
not from a playing point of view but
preparation-wise i knew that i wasn't
the most gift in new zealand so i had to
train harder and do all the stuff
to get to where i got to there i sort of
guess i got up there and
with no dream of being an all black
again because i was in bath i guess i
just
almost relaxed and
and thought you know what you deserve
time to enjoy it yeah and
and unfortunately for bath why you know
they still were paying me to play the
rugby and i was
cruising to be fair
um and then a few things happen around
the club which didn't help my attitude
towards it all you know like
but it's quite almost like because bath
and bath the rugby team is the only team
there's no big sockets team it is it is
a rugby city which is quite unique for
england um there was like there was
local tabloid stuff in and stuff like
that which i was fine
and so i was waking up one morning to be
told that oh apparently it's all through
the media that you're on your last
warning you're going to see you're going
to cut your contract and all this sort
of stuff and it's got it's got quotes
from like the ceo and stuff man
and i was
straight away i was like
tell him i want to see him this
afternoon and uh and it just never
fronted and stuff like that and just
just spiraled a bit so as that
relationship goes um
and then the following year they changed
coaches and um i thought that was going
to be a bit different and i already
knuckled down in the pre-season and
tried to get really prepared well and
then
the new coaches um it was a good fella
to socialize with but um he's so african
and all he wanted us to do was kick
until we got to the opposition 20. yeah
like i'm like oh
jesus what's the point of me being here
because i've never been accused of being
a great kicking team um so
you know just it just it became a bit of
a mess by the end of it
and i didn't have a year to run on my
contract but i had an option
and in the end i was happy to get out um
i mean i regret there's a lot of things
there i regret my time about but um
there's also things that were coming
from the club that were just
not the environment you wanted to be a
part of you know so
it was it would have been nice to have
had the time again there but um yeah i
mean
it was what it was it was a good eye
opener for me and and in so many regards
like i realized that you do have to
prepare
every week you know like your life
depends on as opposed to i'm up here now
i can sort of cruise a bit yeah um did
you get you got found out pretty quickly
it didn't help but i went from about a
97 kg five eight to about a hundred kg
five eight
but that that wasn't a great uh great
conditioning aspect of mine those
tuesday nights will do it
tuesday nights and too many pies uh
there's a wonderful diet up there if you
allow it today we had a full we had a
full-time shift at uh
at the training base yeah let's say like
obviously it was every trip
and we've got breakfast lunch and
sometimes an afternoon tea but an
afternoon tea would essentially be
a three-course meal roast the words and
like i mean i've i mean i love the food
so i was thinking this is heaven and
i've never had a cooked breakfast in my
life on a training day in new zealand
and yet here i am with bacon eggs
sausages and i'm just thinking this is
this is what it's about guys
so yeah needless to say i quickly went
high up into those early 100s
that's good stuff but you obviously
sacrificed a fair bit of money to return
back to new zealand but um no regrets
doing that you had a hell of a time like
you've already sort of spoke about
coming back playing for waikato winning
the ram philly shield few things that
must stand out for you
yeah i mean yeah it was it was funny i
just woke up one day and i go right i'm
done i want to go back to new zealand um
if people was telling me don't don't
come don't come because you know like
obviously left on
um a good moment and uh
you know a lot of my close people and
people respect were like don't come back
um you can only go down from here
but i was like well you know what like
if if i come back and i'm a mess then
dystopian you know
um i'd rather have come back and have a
crack because at the time i was sort of
30ish early 30s and i was like well
you know it's too early to retire but
it's also
you know not too late to if you've got
any regrets you know that you want to
achieve or anything like that then come
back and roll the dice and i guess uh i
didn't have any when i made the decision
um i didn't have any correspondence off
the chief so i just said the white kid i
got we got in touch with waka and they
said oh look there's only a minimum deal
there's 17 000.
and i'm like oh that's fine
we'll pick that up and just go from
there and then a couple of couple days
later got a message from my agent saying
oh
rings is keen to meet you
i was like well i'm actually halfway to
the coromandel but when does he want to
meet me and they're going on about now
it's time
so
i had my own me my man going for a fish
over the cotton handle and i was just
like
and so just turned around and the three
hour round trip back to hamilton um
when he went and had a beer with rings
and
rin said uh i'm saying like why do you
want to be a chief again i said well you
guys seem to know how to win them i'll
be pretty keen on winning one
and uh he's like yep okay you make it
heaven from your end i'll make it happen
from this end and
we were shook the hands had a couple
more beers and i was back on my way to
the coromandel to go fishing
easy is that well you didn't quite win
one did you but you got pretty close
yeah a couple of semi-finals and yeah
the day like i don't
you know like would have been nice with
one one but at least i was part of a
part of an outfit that gave it a red hot
crack and
you know there's a couple of couple
games you probably slipped during the
during the uh season which you know at
that time home home advantage in the
finals was almost
almost the gate to winning it you know
so um but yeah as i say certainly can
leave that aspect was absolutely not a
no regrets at all but you did win the
shield um and we've heard damian on
already who spoke about the and brad
webber i think i think they're both in
your site at the time and spoke about
the after party at your house one of the
great dudes
yeah
i mean it might have been for them um i
was still patching up the uh messing up
the aftermath of it for months after but
uh i'm sure i had a great couple of days
what was it like playing with all those
young guys who were coming through you
come back more more experienced guy just
won the rugby world cup a few years
earlier
all of them would have looked up to you
what was it like what's the relationship
like
yeah well he didn't look up to me for
long they quickly uh started ripping me
to pieces but uh
like as i say it was
rugby special sort of environments
because you can quickly forget that
you're 30 and they're 19 to 20 and all
of a sudden you think that you're the
same age but uh
it was great coming back with that group
um obviously
something informed relationships with
the guys you've mentioned and and that
like that they're more than rugby in
that now so
um you know like it's bizarre because at
the time when you're a 30 year old you
think about your average 20 year old and
you're thinking well i'm probably not
going to be mates with a 20 year old but
that's that's the way it turned out with
the rugby boys and uh
and yeah it's uh
obviously
pretty like-minded people apart from
apart from damien is obviously a lot
more serious than the most um but uh the
rest of them very relaxed individuals
and uh it say great great to be part of
it and not just them but like to come
back and play in the chiefs that contain
the brody metallics
for example you know you need to play
with the big guzz and you know like
he'll go down as one of the all-time
greats so
pretty cool to cool to play with him and
stuff like that so
um no pretty it was pretty pretty
special to come back and be a part of
that crew
and one guy who did look up to you i
know for sure was tim o'malley and i do
want to hear the story about when he
asked you for a photo at halftime
running up the running up the tunnel
surely this is a yard
no it's it's not actually and i'm
surprised he did because uh it's that
year last year i played an epc with
counties and uh
we're in a wretched year and but we was
we were
just before half time um
they got us back in the game and i'm
sure it was terminal someone else was
playing in the midfield that day for an
intercept and i think timmy now and i
plucked it out and we scored under the
post and because i had a relationship
with finlay so i turn and just start
feeding it for friendly saying what are
you doing rick what are you making that
sort of call on half time for you just
giving us the game back and i'm just
feeding it to him and i'm not sure if
paul toomey got a got an earful event
too or who i was giving it to but uh
half out of the tunnel the great man
asking for a photo after the game so
um yeah and then obviously we can make
good mates in uh
in japan as uh green rockets teammates
but no it is a true story it's never
happened before
um
i thought what a lovely gentleman i
certainly stopped uh sledging him after
that
oh that cracks me up so much i love it
and then your teammates are following
you over in japan so why did you go to
japan was it just a top up
yeah i mean yeah i mean there's no
hiding from the fact that that's uh it's
a good spot to make money um but
after
uh
um pulling into japan was good you know
like it got i used to love of the rugby
backs um and yeah no it's like they
you paid you paid obviously more money
you've ever seen but then you've
then you've got guys who just appreciate
the game for what it is and they forget
about the money and all of that and the
professionalism and
you go out and do your bit for the
company in the weekend and then you know
they're just happy to have you there and
you know want to lose you you make sure
you have a good time after the game of
the boys and it's just it's just a
refreshing place obviously certainly
knowing
the japanese man and shinjuku doesn't
know a thing about hong kong
so you can walk around pretty anonymous
there
um
and it's just like it's it's just a
great place to go you know and
you know like there's challenges there's
challenges there obviously you know your
downtime can sometimes
you get too much of it at times over
there sort of damning the other night
and i see it's like you almost i said
you want to be training more often he
goes yeah you're right like you
literally get um
you get too much down time to be stuck
in your apartment but um
i mean i could i couldn't talk about it
highly enough you know just from a rugby
point of view
it's not over coached and over
structured
you know there's still an aspect of you
still at school playing yeah footy but
that enjoyment factor and i remember
first couple
games up there when i put in what i
thought was a beautiful raking wipers
kick and your wingers would look at you
thinking well who's chasing that because
i'm not you know
and i'm like i found grass you know we
could catch them in the corner but
literally 12 o'clock one o'clock game go
out throw the ball around go hard and
then you know the boys will the boys
will have a social party as you know for
social they call for social every
weekend there'll be another reason to
have a social and we'll be we'll have
booked out some uh where you can drink
and all you can eat clothes for two
hours and it'll be
clap your hands and see on monday sort
of thing it's uh
just a wonderful wonderful way to live
life though yeah and you must have spent
some time at karaoke over there
especially after your
masked singer
i've never seen this before till last
night someone sent the question and i
looked it up
couldn't believe it how did you get
roped into that one
i'm surprised you i'm surprised you're
still interviewing me after all the
respect would have gone um
look uh you know as i say it was a long
time between paychecks and when the
master became knocking oh i had to
answer um
anyone that's been in the karaoke
booth with me in tokyo would have told
you he should be nowhere near a singing
show that's for sure but uh as i say it
was a long time between uh paychecks so
i had to do it
what were the nerves like before going
on that that must have been right up
there
i thought nothing of it and uh
did all well until point a bit of a
pre-recording and all the rest of it and
the voice stuff and did all that and
then on filming day
you're locked in a room and then they
bring you out and you're standing there
in a six foot four or six foot well
about an eight foot tall mower costume
and you're thinking yourself what have i
signed up for here um
you're thinking how much are they paying
me for this was it enough
um and then uh like all along i'd been
told so i said look i don't dance so i'm
not gonna dance on stage you're like
yeah no no it's no problem um you'll
have backup dancers it'll be fine
so it's all okay sweetie i'll go stand
out there for a minute and a half and
just go put up with her then all of a
sudden i'm filming that they say oh no
he hasn't anyone told you you don't have
backup dancers you're gonna have to be
around i was like
and that's when that's when the split
was just dripping
and then i was i was
drove off after her
and then i sort of tried to forget about
it tried to get on with life and then
obviously
months after
you know the show's coming out
where can i hide where can i bury myself
for a couple of days one of us blows
over
well i suppose you're so used to
coughing criticism
well i did wonder after it why did i put
myself
into the firing line again
but uh yeah
i mean
people
people people who took it seriously were
probably a bit offended that i'd be on a
singing show but uh people would saw
what it was probably uh you know
oh so how did the retirement from rugby
come about was that your own call did
you was it or was it injuries
no i mean i mean yeah the body the body
in that last year in japan was starting
to creak and you know like
was starting to
do things like calves which are old
men's injuries so yeah but in the end in
the end i sort of i just came back
obviously when cobra hit over there and
we all jumped on that emergency plane
out of marina
and um
and i just i didn't really i never
didn't really make a hard call about it
um talked to my agent about it and said
look if if something pops up that's
bloody good then
i'm all go so i kept training for i used
to you know during lockdown and that
when there wasn't a whole lot to do for
that time so i kept training um
didn't play nbc obviously and just
trained and
just sort of stayed and then a couple a
couple did come through but um not ones
that sort of made you want to get to the
airport and go and do it all again you
know so
um and then sort of just sort of i guess
sort of just drifted off and um then
that's when i guess a few of the things
like this job came up and um and other
things came up so
and you know my singer came up so they
tried me over for another month
um doing a big announcement um as far as
i've retired from rugby um i didn't need
to call a press conference
uh so i just sort of just drifted off
really um like obviously he was chatting
around that american stuff and and all
that sort of stuff but
to uproot the family he would have for
for not you know not huge wedge these
days you know it would have been a bit
probably selfish from from me so
um so just we parked up at home and
started to build our little life there
so
yeah um i'm pretty content with how it
all unfolded i mean it wasn't
it wasn't great finishing on the covered
season yeah yeah
so you're definitely done though is this
is this your announcement
is this right now
no one is you wanted no one's wanted it
mate so you can have it here we go
steven donald retires from rugby
officially
eventually i've actually i've actually
been in talks with the local club team
so
they're putting a contract proposal to
me right now so we'll see we'll see what
comes with it
it'll be about two free handles of
saturday so it'll be tough
yeah what's the thing you miss most
about rugby is it that side of it
uh that side of it being a part of a
team and the rest of it but i have
noticed in the year or two since i've
been out of it that that
competitive
um aspect on a on a friday night going
to bed knowing that i'm about to [ __ ]
sleep because i'm nervous about what's
gonna you know what's what's gonna have
unfold tomorrow
um yeah the competitiveness you know
i don't think you lose that and that's
what i've
that's why i still miss and and crave
and every now and again watch tv and see
people like kahui stealing and living at
the force and think well maybe i can do
it too you know so
those times you have after a good win or
whatever you know
oh one of the greats absolutely well as
always we've gone to instagram for some
questions
that is one of the greatest journeys
ever but um plenty of questions came
through i've chosen the best ten
uh most of the questions came in were
around your nuts so victor obviously
mentioned mentioned that you had big
nuts and i didn't think much of it i
thought it was just the um
[Laughter]
i thought it was just because you're ice
cold when you kick that um penalty but
there must be more to it because kirsty
mentioned it too when i came on so
no she asked about it
i don't know i don't know what victor
was going on about there and i was quite
offended by him to be fair uh
so massive nuts or
[Laughter]
let me guess there's some pretty high
profile uh followers of yours that text
messages in a lot
oh there's a few a few probably seen you
in the shower
yeah i can imagine a few you think this
is hilarious
okay the other one was how do you get
the nickname beaver this one came in a
bit
no i just uh
oh
as a kid uh had two front teeth for
probably longer than a kid should have
there's no supporting those supporting
aspects
and uh one of my good mates uh thought i
look like a beaver and
it's uh you know obviously not the most
easy on the eye child and uh i haven't
grown into most easy on your head but um
he was just cruel and unfortunately it
stuck and uh bieber just followed me
everywhere well that's crazy i don't
know it came back from that long ago
yeah i know everyone anticipates a lot
better story than that um but
like that okay next one did jimmy cowan
actually stick up for you like he did in
the movie
of course he did
anyone knows jimmy knows uh you want him
in your corner uh in any situation so no
jimmy uh jimmy's a wonderful man but uh
he is there when you need him most
that's not sure no yeah okay how hairy
are you really
uh quite an interesting question there
um it blows a lot of people's minds that
uh from the knees and the elbows down
very hearing um
and then
pretty poor elsewhere outfit
yeah yeah
true no chance
no it's like sprinkles oh yeah i would
imagine you having a big bush under
there i know i know i know it's uh
obviously
hearing neck hearing arms from elbow
down and hairy legs from your shin down
but yeah
dude
i don't know
well it's about
no good for me
good for the quads though
great for the quads a lot of heavy heavy
massages okay next one best team piss up
there would have been a few
oh jesus
uh
she's really having to dive deep now um
sort of mentioned that all black one
didn't yeah that one yeah
all black pullback one in wellington um
before the parade was was probably the
best all black one
uh best
chiefs one
uh
it was a controversial one and got a few
people in trouble but the
flight probably probably from the moment
we walked off loftus to the moment we
about thursday back in hamilton after
that 2009 final um
it's fair to say the boys didn't prepare
themselves to go into a business car's
flight on the way home and i don't think
business class was prepared for the
chiefs to come into that flight after
losing to loft at loftus by 50.
um a few guys never got more contracts
after that uh it was quite a
controversial
a few medical people got a few of the
sleeping pills got put in the wrong
people's uh drinks and uh
there's some repercussions from there um
but uh
yeah it was all the same it was good
with uh we turned into an impromptu
costume one two because
we've gone to the uh police second store
in pretoria during that week you know
what it's like trying to fill in a week
in pretoria not easy uh so we went
shopping and got all this army kit um
from their store and
cox had a gas mask i had the full uh
like up the fenders outfit with the vest
and the works and uh we decided that
after that lost why not get into it so
yeah that was probably that was probably
the best cheese piss up and
well why couldn't white killer
well any
every week
it was some good waitress
oh good stuff okay next one favorite
player to watch
favorite player to watch uh
oh
talking chief wilson when i was growing
up
it was just
just silky
just an array of skills chip and chase
yeah
it was pretty it was pretty special
watching his prime goldie one of the
greatest
okay next one next one the swiss
question shout out to the new major
sponsor but if you could get a video
call from anyone in the world who would
it be
um or pete sampras actually oh a legend
going back going into my tennis days and
another man that's very hairy
from the elbow yeah alike kind of
[Laughter]
yeah possibly possibly but uh he'd be up
there have you heard that before pete
sam press look-alike
sure no
oh no sure
[Laughter]
okay two more
advice to deal with public criticism
um oh
well you thought i learned after it all
that you know
you are who you are and
you're not who that person says you are
so
at the end of the day it's got to be and
it's corny as hell but it's just like
being true to you like
being
being you really um
you've just got to somehow just block it
um
you know like a lot of boys go through
it and complain about it you know like
the easiest thing would be to ignore
social media but it's such a part of
everyone's lives these days it'd be
tough for them tough for that younger
generation too but the other part of it
is just just be
you you know you like you're not
necessarily
um david mckenzie of a rugby player
you're damian mckenzie and you know like
as an example don't don't your identity
is not based on
you know who you are
as a rugby player or what have you you
just got to be you the person and
if people have an issue with that then
that's fine but you you know who you are
so i just i just click on just
block it out and just ignore it because
they don't know you yeah jeez i like
that from the man who's got probably the
most last question
beaver's best piece of advice this will
be good
uh
oh i need to come up with something good
but i'm just i'm just coming up
uh
it feels like the right thing to do
oh short sharp to the point i love that
i knew you'd come up trumps
oh one of the great ways to finish one
of the great podcasts mate really
appreciate you giving up your time i
know you're flat out at the moment with
all your jobs and i really appreciate
you coming on here for oh almost an hour
and a half with one of the greatest
yards we've ever had mate really
appreciate
you coming on and i'm going through your
journey
thanks for having me if you're honored
you've had an array of superstars on
here so it's great to uh great to join
them okay one of the greats appreciate
it
cheers
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
you